[Music]
in the lead-up to the era of the wild
the kingdom of hyrule enjoyed a time of
peace and prosperity which lasted for
many
thousands of years but an ancient
prophecy foretold by an unknown fortune
teller ushered in
an end to this era of peace and the
means by which this would come to be was
that of a long forgotten cycle of
destruction which had since
faded into legend the stories tell of an
ominous presence that would arise from
deep below
hyrule castle again and again throughout
history
an ancient faceless and speechless evil
with
only one goal in mind obliterate the
kingdom of hyrule
and everyone in it the rise of this
entity and the attack that follows has
been given the name
the calamity by those who witnessed it
and survived it
but by the time the next one takes place
so much time has passed that the event
fades into legend and future generations
regard them as
stories and fairy tales rather than
history it's unknown exactly
how many calamities have taken place
throughout hyrule's past
as of today only two are documented but
it's apparent that it happened enough
times
that a pattern was recognized ten
thousand years
every ten millennia the calamity
resurges once again like clockwork
and the evil presence behind these
attacks has since been dubbed
calamity ganon the name ganon finds its
origin
all the way back to an age long
forgotten long before the events in the
era of the wild
the zelda timeline has drastically
changed with the introduction of breath
of the wild the newest
addition to the mainline zelda series as
of the making of this video
it takes place so far in the future that
all other adventures we've experienced
in the last decades have been reduced to
a single marker on this new timeline
the distant past sometimes referred to
as times unknown
beyond this point we have the events of
10 000 years ago
the first documented case of a calamity
taking place
100 years ago which marks the beginning
of the most recent calamity
and the present which is where breath of
the wild takes place
and the same calamity reaches its
conclusion the gap between 10
000 years ago and the distant past is
one which we know the least about
in fact we don't even know how much time
spans between these points
could be twenty thousand years fifty
thousand or
even more it's been made clear that the
evil known as calamity ganon dates back
all the way to the distant past and has
stubbornly persisted over the ages
making a continuous effort to bring the
kingdom to its knees
but whispers say that the monstrosity we
see today was once
a mortal man a king from the desert who
went by the name of ganondorf and at
some point in his life obtained a piece
of the most powerful relic in existence
the triforce with it he became the
self-proclaimed king of evil
also referred to as the demon king and
allowed him to transform into a
beast-like alter-ego
ganon with his newfound power he
attempted to rule the kingdom by force
again and again but every time he did an
incarnation of a hero and a princess
would rise up to face him preventing his
evil plans from coming to fruition
every time during his first appearance
in ocarina of time
ganondorf was never killed but instead
sealed away
this temporary victory didn't last long
however as it took him only a few
decades to break free once again which
led to the events of the wind waker
and twilight princess two games taking
place roughly around the same time
though in their own respective timeline
at the conclusion of these two stories
ganondorf seems to have been felt for
good by the legendary blade of evil's
bane
the master sword which was driven
through his chest in one timeline and
into his skull in the other turning him
to stone this is the last we saw of the
man from the desert and his fate
whereabouts and whether or not he's
somehow alive still have remained
unknown until now
the 2019 reveal trailer for the sequel
to breath of the wild
hints at a return of the demon king
after ages of being lost to time
for some an uncertainty still exists
but his general appearance gerudo marked
jewelry and clothing
as well as parts of the music heard in
the trailer all but confirms that this
is indeed ganondorf back in the flesh
though one might notice that he doesn't
exactly look as lively as he once did
rather than the tall muscular and
imposing stature that we're familiar
with
we're instead presented with a slender
shriveled up
corpse bent over backwards in what seems
like a state of pure agony
its skin dried up and mummified two
dark empty sockets where his eyes used
to be and even his attire seems to have
decayed with age
whatever happened to the demon king he's
clearly been here a very
very long time hidden away in darkness
deep underground somewhere but even as a
corpse ganondorf seems to be anything
but harmless streams of malice are seen
flowing from the body in all directions
like tentacles reaching out into the
underground chamber
meanwhile a mysterious green glowing
hand wearing some sort of golden
bracelet
is seen latched onto his chest clawing
into his flesh
which is also where the malice seems to
be flowing outwards from
the scene portrayed here in the 2019
reveal trailer
has confirmed our suspicions that
calamity gannon as we saw him in breath
of the wild
was not the end game the swirling
pig-like menace seen soaring above the
peaks of hyrule castle was just another
manifestation of malice
of which its source can be traced back
to the corpse we see here
deep underground this revelation has
brought forth numerous theories and
speculations as to what this
all means the main consensus as of right
now
is that ganondorf might have been sealed
by this green hand a long time ago
in the distant past since then the
gerudo king has been trapped
frozen in time his only option being to
release
malice to slowly accumulate over time
until enough of it is built up to
release another calamity
on the world above as for the hand
clutching his chest
theories vary greatly some claim it's an
incarnation of an ancient hero
others still think it might be a sage a
twilight
even zelda's mother has been theorized
in some cases
but one prevalent theory is that this
hand belonged to a member of an
ancient race called the zonai the zonai
are by far the greatest mystery found in
breath of the wild
the little exposition we have describes
them as a savage
warlike tribe who predominantly lived in
and around the farren region
long ago the reason why so little is
known about them
is because they've since completely
disappeared off the face of the earth
all they leave behind is some of their
architecture from megalithic
structures to some stray walls statues
and pillars
and this sudden disappearance remains a
total mystery to this day
had this been the extent of it there
would have been very little reason to
believe that this mystery would ever be
solved but when the sequel to breath of
the wild was announced
this all suddenly changed throughout the
underground caves and tunnels depicted
in the trailer
zonai architecture is seen scattered
about
from their iconic pillars to a large
stone bridge
wall decorations wall paintings and an
impressive entrance way decorated in
their recognizable style
there's no doubt that these are indeed
of zonai origin
which is the biggest reason why people
have associated this green glowing hand
to this mysterious tribe
we're not here to dispute the connection
between the zonai and ganondorf's body
in fact given the little evidence that
we do have
we actually fully agree with this idea
what we're here to do is to challenge
the idea that the scene laid out before
us
this room the green hand the corpse the
spiraling energy the malice leaking out
is not a seal but rather a deliberate
act by ganondorf to prolong his
existence in the world
it's easy to see why people would
conclude that the demon king is under
some sort of seal
he's been sealed numerous times in the
past three of which he was in his human
form ganondorf
and not his alter-ego ganon so to think
that this is simply yet
another seal in which he finds himself
trapped is only logical given the track
record
there were even some early theories
claiming that the green particles
coiling around the demon king's body
spelled out the phrase seal ganon but
other theorists have since refuted and
debunked this idea which relies on being
a little too lenient with your
comparisons
but when we look a bit closer at the
scene at hand there is something very
odd about
it the entrance to the room as well as
the bridge leading to it
is decked out with imagery of ganon the
cave-painting zelda studies depict the
gerudo king on horseback surrounded by
some of his own followers
weapons drawn as if riding into battle
the room that holds the body has
large decorated spires pointing towards
a platform in the center
on which his body rests if this was
indeed a seal what's with all the ganon
imagery
the decorations and the cave paintings
heralding him as some sort of leader
there's evidence to suggest that this
giant underground lair was not built as
a prison for the demon king
but instead in his honor this could mean
that instead of being sealed without his
consent
he was instead placed here on this altar
willingly
this sounds crazy we know but before you
dispute this
let's first explain why we think this
might be the case
starting with the motive because who in
their right mind would want to place
themselves in such an agonizing position
and allow themselves to be turned into a
lifeless dried-up
corpse willingly what benefit could that
bring
well my friends this is where we dive
into the territory
of the lich
among fantasy media we find many types
of undead creatures
from zombies to vampires mummy skeletons
ghouls
the list goes on among these undead
entities we find
the lich originating from the old
english lich meaning corpse it was first
introduced as a fantasy creature in the
1976 fantasy role
game dungeons and dragons they are
described as a powerful magic wielder
such as a mage
wizard or warlock who at some point in
their mortal life transformed themselves
into an undead being and as far as
fantasy creatures go
liches are among the most dangerous and
notorious ones out there
what sets a lich apart from your typical
zombie is that they are
extremely intelligent having kept all
their memories and knowledge from the
time when they were still alive
and because they are practically
immortal they are able to continue to
study and gather knowledge for thousands
upon thousands of years without ever
having to worry about aging
death illness or any other problems the
living have to deal with
so has ganondorf become a lich in order
to answer this question we have to
compare the two
side to side and see if we can find any
correlation
the rules surrounding glitches may vary
between different types of media
obviously writers are allowed to take
some creative liberty here and there and
the lore has been expanded multiple
times but there are some key
requirements that have to be met
in order to be classified as a lich one
of the most important ones being that
besides being a powerful magic wielder
liches are masters in the art of
necromancy even when they were still
alive
as a matter of fact transforming oneself
into a lich is considered
extremely difficult and requires an
expert understanding of dark magic
without the knowledge of necromancy it
would be impossible to achieve this
transformation and ganondorf
is definitely no stranger to this he's
had a wide array of undead at his
disposal since his very first appearance
all of which are described as being
reanimated through the use of magic
even when housing his powers into others
like zen who was a nobody before he met
the demon king
impressive feats of necromancy are on
display time and time again
but by far the most impressive display
of necromancy by ganon has to be
the blood moon which through the use of
his malice resurrects every last one of
his deceased
minions on a country-wide scale in one
fell swoop
it is one of the most powerful forms of
necromancy ever displayed in fantasy
so yes ganondorf is a necromancer and a
powerful one at that
but this isn't enough to be classified
as a lich
another key detail is that their soul is
bonded to a physical object also known
as a phylactery this is how they are
able to stay
sentient even though technically they
don't have a brain anymore
the phylactery is also their one and
only weakness
destroy the phylactery and it's game
over for them as such
protecting their phylactery is one of
their highest priorities
this is one thing we cannot prove
indefinitely as of right now as we don't
have enough information about the
upcoming sequel but if ganondorf does
indeed have a phylactery
it would present a new and unique way to
defeat the gerudo king once and for all
instead of sealing him away once again
or getting stabbed by the master sword
which has proven ineffective in the long
run
given the fact that he's back once again
perhaps the only way to truly deal with
the demon king is not to destroy his
body but his
soul as well a phylactery can be
anything really
many different types of objects have
been used from jewelry to staffs to
gemstones and as for ganondorf
the possibilities are endless the jewel
on his forehead which
is seen glowing even when his body seems
to be dormant the entire room he resides
in
or even hyrule castle as a whole which
may sound ridiculous but there is
practically no limit to what a
phylactery can be
an entire building or even city can
serve this purpose
as described in the dnd manual it would
definitely explain why he moves the
entire castle with him
aside from that like i said the
possibilities are endless
liches have bounded their souls to a
comet a bloodline
another lich as long as it's something
physical it can serve as a phylactery
now before moving on to the next and
final chapter in this theory let's first
go over some of the smaller details
about a lich and see how they stack up
against ganondorf
powerful wizard check a corpse or
skeletal-like appearance
check flaming eyes check a strong
motivation to want to live forever
either because of unfinished business
hatred or wanting to outlive your
enemies check check
and check it is worth mentioning that
not every lich is inherently evil but in
many cases they are associated with a
type of madness
i mean you have to be at least a little
bit mad to want to live the rest of
eternity as a walking corpse
and this too fits perfectly with the way
ganondorf is described
if you remember the quote from king rome
at the very beginning of the video
he states that ganondorf was born into
the kingdom but that his transformation
into malice created the horror we see
now but what exactly does that mean
transformation into malice we know it's
something that transpired at the tail
end of the distant past
long before the events of 10 000 years
ago the one part of hyrule's history
where we know very little about
but there is one passage in creating a
champion that does mention this event as
well
it describes that quote ganon having
lost his reason becomes
calamity ganon a pure incarnation of
hatred and malice for the royal family
of hyrule and the chosen hero
having lost his reason definitely hints
that ganon or ganondorf having been
struck by
some sort of madness which lends itself
perfectly for his decision to become a
lich
additionally right before the fight with
dark beast ganon zelda says that he has
given up on reincarnation and assumed
his pure and raged form
however it has since come to light that
this was actually an incorrect
translation from japanese to english
in the original japanese version she
says that this form was born
from his obsessive refusal to give up on
revival
the complete opposite but no matter
which quote you regard as the correct
one
both apply to ganondorf's decision to
transform himself into an undead
immortal being
yes his obsession and hatred is what
motivates him and fuels his refusal to
die and keep coming back but the english
text is not incorrect either
technically he isn't reincarnating
anymore instead it's still the same body
which he may have purposely frozen in
time in order to persist in this world
and this leads into the final chapter
because so far we have yet to cover one
essential aspect since how does one
actually become a lich in the first
place
the ritual involving the transformation
into a lich varies
sometimes a blood sacrifice is performed
other times it involves a potion or brew
which is to be consumed by the user
there's definitely some wiggle room
within the law but as we've discussed
before
the one performing the ritual must be a
powerful magic wielder
have expert knowledge on necromancy and
bind their soul to a phylactery but
there's one more
crucial detail that must be met and
that's that a lich
can't be created against their will i.e
it's something that they must do
willingly or else it just doesn't work
so let's take a closer look at the
scenery setup in the reveal trailer for
breath of the wild 2.
as we've discussed earlier the cave link
and zelda are exploring has imagery of
ganon all over the place
which hints that this cave might have
been built for him
and perhaps at his command this is
definitely something that isn't
uncommon for ganon to do he's a somewhat
egotistical ruler
and insists on putting his imagery up
anywhere he calls home
or conquers from his enemies as such
it's not much of a stretch to think that
the room his corpse resides in was made
by his design as well
a place where he would complete his
transformation into malice
as described by breath of the wild
stories from the distant past
the room definitely screams ritual
it has an altar to hold his body spires
pointing towards the center
and with the recent trailer for breath
of the wild it's now become clear that
the floor of the altar has some sort of
ancient scripture written on it this may
seem trivial but a common trait of the
lich ritual
is that there's often runes or scripture
involved in the soul binding process
not to mention the green energy
spiraling upwards
too has elements of an unknown script to
it
a counter-argument to this scene being a
deliberate act by ganondorf would be
that the gerudo king
seems to have been in a state of serious
pain and agony
his corpse is bent over backwards arms
out to the side
mouth wide open as if screaming in pain
as well as
puncture holes littered across his chest
and hands
but this doesn't necessarily disprove a
deliberate act
just because this ritual was out of his
own free will
it doesn't mean that it was a pleasant
experience in fact the transformation
into a lich
never is and when we take a closer look
at the corpse there's one thing that
just
doesn't add up there doesn't seem to
have been any restraints on his body
at all no ropes shackles or chains or
anything that would have held the demon
king in place
it's hard to believe that ganondorf the
king of evil
would allow himself to be killed without
resistance
in twilight princess he was chained to a
giant rock during his execution
and even this didn't hold him back isn't
it also strange if he was killed while
standing up on an
altar in the middle of this ornate room
with a pyramid structure right above him
as if by design again not restrained in
any visible way
a brief shot in the trailer shows a
flash on the wall revealing a silhouette
of ganondorf
in what is presumably his final moment
before he died
not only does this confirm that he was
killed in this
room but here too no restraints are
visible on his body
eliminating any possibility that
restraints were there but removed
afterwards
the scene laid out here could very well
be depicting the moment
ganondorf transformed into malice and
achieved immortality by mummifying his
body
and from the perspective of ganondorf
this absolutely makes sense
though ganondorf definitely has a longer
life span than that of the average
gerudo
most likely because of the triforce of
power he does show signs of
ageing after countless failed attempts
to rule over hyrule his intense hatred
for the kingdom and its royal family
caused him to go
mad and he decided to achieve
immortality by any means so that he can
set his malice free upon hyrule in an
endless cycle of destruction for all
eternity
ganondorf may have been reduced to a
corpse a shell of his former self
but from his perspective he's in a
better spot here than he's ever been
he's immortal safely hidden away and
nobody even seems to know that he exists
he can wreak havoc on the world above
with his malice without ever being in
danger of being killed or sealed away
all the while keeping all of his
memories his intelligence and knowledge
from his past life
though his appearance may be a sight for
sore eyes this is by far the most
dangerous form of ganondorf in the
entire series
and if you think ganondorf wouldn't be
crazy enough to willfully mummify
himself to prolong his life
the sheikah monks who lived 10 000 years
ago did the exact same thing
they purposefully placed themselves on
an altar starved and mummified
themselves
all for the purpose of extending their
lifespan long enough to test the hero
destined to fight the next calamity
if the sheikah were willing to go that
far imagine what ganondorf would be
capable of
speaking of the sheikah monks because of
the way the trailer is portrayed
we were quick to conclude that
ganondorf's body springs back to life
because some sort of seal was just
lifted from him
either intentionally or by a mistake
from lincoln zelda but as we've just
demonstrated
this doesn't have to be the case at all
perhaps
ganondorf's always been able to move he
just doesn't because he has no reason to
he has his malice to do that and in
between calamities he's essentially in
hibernation for another 10
000 years waiting for his malice to
build back up again
which is very similar to monk maz koshia
who also doesn't move until he has a
reason to
maybe ganondorf starts to move not
because a seal was broken
but simply because he feels threatened
by link and zelda's presence
this would also be textbook lich
behavior it's considered
extremely rare to ever encounter a lich
in your lifetime
they prefer to stay hidden away out of
public sight
since as we mentioned before leaving
their phylactery undefended
can mean the end for them this man has
been safely hidden
deep underground for millennia and here
comes
marching into his lair the two
individuals in the world that actually
stand a chance at killing
him so yes there's an argument to be
made that what we're looking at here
isn't a seal but the leftovers of a
ritual that was performed
countless years ago we've assumed before
that the green hand is holding the demon
king in place
and even that it might be extracting his
life force
but what if it was the other way around
and it's ganondorf who's sucking the
life force out of whatever this being
used to be
it would explain why only a hand remains
and why the green energy is spiraling
away from it
as if slowly being dissolved this is
again a common trait of a lich though
they don't need to eat
sleep or breathe over the course of its
life it must eventually consume
mortal souls to sustain the magic that
protects his undead form
in a recent example we saw ganon
demanding a blood sacrifice from the
newest addition to his line of followers
the yiga clan yanking out their souls as
their lifeless bodies dropped onto the
fields of central hyrule
an act so vile that it made the yiga who
had previously worshipped ganon for
thousands of years
rethink their allegiance and switch
sides at the last moment
so could something similar have
transpired many years ago
it would definitely explain a lot of the
spirit imagery seen in the trailer
luminous stones green energy a
disembodied hand which seems to be
slowly disintegrating over time
even the helpers that some people hear
when reversing the audio
could ganondorf have been consuming
these poor souls for the past millennia
to preserve his immortality
if so one question remains whom do these
souls belong to
and this is what brings us full circle
back again
to the zonai a tribe who suddenly and
mysteriously disappeared
tens of thousands of years ago but not
before building
impressive feats of architecture
including a vast underground
cave seemingly devoted to a certain
individual
could this mean that we've
misinterpreted the zonai all this time
making them out as good guys enemies of
ganondorf
while in reality they may have actually
helped him in his ritual
they're described as having been
powerful magic wielders
magic which could have benefited
ganondorf in achieving this goal of
immortality
perhaps even they regret this decision
since which would explain why we might
hear calls for help
and why the green hand seems to side
with link
but the possible relationship between
ganondorf and the zonai is a topic too
big to fit into one video
so this was just the first half of the
story which will be continued
over on my channel celtic here we'll
dive deeper into the connections between
the zonai and the demon king
their motivations and the evidence that
suggests that the zonai may not have
been on the right side of history
after all so if you want to go check
that out the link will be in the
description
end card and in the pinned comment down
below
before ending the video i have to give
credit where credit is due
first of all of course a big thanks to
celtic for joining me in this one
like the man said be sure to check out
his video as well
second a big thanks to rewan link for
providing the animations of ganondorf
i think most of you are familiar with
this work and it's amazing so be sure
to check out his channel as well another
big shout out goes to one of my patreons
johnny peacock he's the one who brought
the lich similarities to my attention
and essentially set this entire theory
into motion so
again thank you johnny for sharing your
ideas and educating me on this subject
lastly i need to clarify that there have
been similar theories suggested in the
past
there was a post by wandering salad on
reddit about the possibility of
ganondorf becoming a lich in breath of
the wild 2 as early as 2 years ago which
is when the reveal trailer was still
brand new
additionally rinkudo in his truth of the
wild series also suggested that
ganondorf's transformation into a corpse
may have been
intentional though he doesn't use the
term lich it's still at least worth
mentioning
and with that i will conclude this video
i will be saving the new patreon
shoutouts for another time as there
wasn't a lot of time left this video was
literally written voiced and produced in
less than 4 days so
yeah i'm recording this final segment
hours before the video is supposed to go
up
anyway i hope to see you next time this
is dawn
signing off and have a good one
[Music]
you